a special achievement award has been  voted and presented a lady whose beauty  is not only a legend  but a reality merle oberon  I've always looked before and wonder  upon the unique talents of the creators  of our industries special effects one of  the outstanding examples of their  contribution to this or for that matter  to any other year was the Poseidon  Adventure the Academy Board of Governors  has awarded the film a special  achievement award for visual effects so  it's my pleasure to present these awards  to two of the very talented magicians lb  Abbot and ADA flowers  ah it's kind of nice I'd like to thank  the Board of Governors for honoring us  with this tonight and I'd like to turn  it over to Bill I want to thank our  producer mr. Irwin Allen for allowing us  to participate the production of  Poseidon Adventure and last but not  least that marvelous crew that really  worked hard and helped us because  without them it wasn't all possible  thank you  you